CHRIS LAW: Hi, everyone.
I'm Chris Law.
And I'm a product manager
here at Google Cloud.
My mission is to make it easier
for our customers to do more
on Cloud with less effort.
I'm excited to be here today
to tell you about Active Assist
and how it helps you do that.
Look, Cloud can be complicated.
You know it.
We know it.
Everyone knows it.
For many of you,
it can sometimes
feel like Cloud has
more knobs and dials
than this cockpit does.
And this complexity
can be overwhelming.
We've seen that almost
half of C-suite executives
said that complexity
was the factor that
would have the most negative
impacts on their Cloud
computing ROI over
the next five years.
In fact, in some
cases, complexity
can make the cost of
administration and maintenance
higher than the costs of
software and hardware.
When we dig into the
effects of complexity,
we see a few big buckets.
First, complexity
can cause waste.
Things like VMs are
over-provisioned
and discounts aren't
optimized, all
leading to unnecessary costs.
Second, complexity can
cause security gaps.
We see things like access
permissions being given away
too freely and firewall
rule configurations
that are so
confusing that people
are afraid to change them.
Finally, all of this ends up
causing lots of extra work.
Things get misconfigured.
And now you've got to spend your
team's time trying to figure
out how to troubleshoot it all.
Now, what makes this
worse is that some
of the traditional
approaches that people
take to solve these challenges
don't work well or don't scale.
Some companies try to
keep hiring more people
to address the problem.
But the reality is that the
talent pool available is small.
And it takes forever to hire.
We at Google face
this issue too.
Other companies go ahead
and just buy more resources.
But that ends up
being unsustainable
and adds more complexity.
And finally, some
others have tried just
to write more code
or widgets to help.
But we hear from them
that maintaining that code
is costly, and ultimately,
it's not their core mission.
At Google, we believe the answer
is intelligence and automation.
Today's IT environments,
whether on-prem or in the Cloud,
feel like a car from the 1970s.
Everything is manual.
And you've got to look
over your shoulder,
shift manually,
look at a paper map,
all while getting
bad gas mileage.
We want to upgrade your
Cloud and provide experiences
like modern cars and beyond.
How can we provide tools
like blind spot sensors
and GPS that make your current
Cloud experience markedly
better?
Ultimately, we're on
a journey to a future
where we want to be able to
automate everything for you.
It won't happen overnight.
But we are looking to move your
Cloud forward in the same way
that Google's Waymo is
moving cars forward.
We're excited to introduce
you to Active Assist,
here to actively assist you.
So what is Active Assist?
It's a new solution
that brings together
an array of intelligent features
which all have a common goal--
to make it easier for you
to optimize your Cloud
while reducing manual effort.
The best of both worlds, right?
We asked ourselves,
what could we
do to empower
customers with better
intelligence and automation?
And after speaking
with many of you,
we heard three answers
loud and clear.
First, you want to find out
what went wrong quickly so you
can take action right away.
Second, you want
to prevent mistakes
from happening altogether.
And third, you want to
improve your Cloud easily.
By doing this, we can
deliver on three big things
for our customers.
First, we're going
to give you more ways
to understand how to
optimize your resources
and let you automate that.
Second, we're going to
help you proactively
secure your Cloud
by alerting you
to things that need fixing
before they become a bigger
issue.
And third, all of this aims
to make your lives easier
by reducing the time and
toil that troubleshooting,
analyzing, configuring, and
administering your Cloud
usually takes.
At the end of the
day, Active Assist
aims to help you maximize your
Cloud's overall performance
without you having to be on the
hook to understand every nook
and cranny of your Cloud.
Your Cloud should work for you.
And that's what we aim to do
by helping you automatically
optimize your resources.
For example, we've had
customers like Viewclip
who have been able to take
advantage of recommendations
to quickly optimize
their VMs and save money.
It's not enough to
save money though.
Today security is also
top of mind for everyone.
We're in an age
where organizations
have more and more sensitive
customer information
and hacks can be devastating.
No organization wants to be
on the receiving end of that.
With Active Assist,
we're going to help
you proactively identify
security gaps and maintain
best practices.
In fact, we've had
large customers
who were able to use identity
and access management role
recommendations to help make
their environments more secure,
while reducing the number of
permission that were granted.
Active Assist will help you by
using automation intelligence
to bring key actions
right to your fingertips.
It takes away the guesswork
and the mystery that's normally
required to operate your Cloud.
For example, customers
like HIPAA Vault
were able to use
Network Intelligence
Center to quickly troubleshoot
networking configuration
issues.
By now, you may be
asking, OK, but how
is Active Assist
going to do all this?
The fun answer is
that Active Assist
is going to unlock Google
magic across your Cloud.
We're going to use
our specialities
around data analytics
and machine learning
to power Active Assist.
Active Assist is
a set of features
that cuts across Google Cloud.
So whether you're interested
in security, cost, networking,
compute, data, or our
newest offering, Anthos,
we'll be rolling out a
number of features to help.
To show you some practical
examples of this,
I'm going to turn it over
to Dima Melnyk, who's
a product manager on our team.
DIMA MELNYK: Thanks, Chris.
Hi, everyone.
I'm excited to show you how some
of these intelligent features
that live under the
Active Assist umbrella
can help you solve some of the
practical day-to-day challenges
you face.
And to do this, I'm going
to tell you a little story.
This is Steve.
And he is in charge
of an application.
He helped to architect and
set up the infrastructure
for this application.
And it's been smooth
sailing so far.
This said, he built
it for normal times.
But now with people
generally at home more,
buying patterns changed
almost overnight,
skyrocketing the traffic
to their application.
And scale is hard.
Steve and his
colleagues face a number
of challenges with
their application's
performance, cost, and security.
First thing in the
morning, he gets a call
from Alice, who is in charge
of their customer support
department.
Alice tells Steve they got
slammed with customer calls
over the weekend, complaining
about terrible log
times and overall slowness.
Steve starts to think
about what could be causing
those performance issues.
He contemplates a
couple of places
where they could be hiding.
Is it compute capacity, or
perhaps networking, or the data
infrastructure
layer that he knows
was architected
with some duct tape?
Or maybe it's not even caused
by the Cloud infrastructure
he's in charge of at all.
Honestly, it could be anything.
And the clock is ticking.
And Steve needs to move fast.
He's worried that going
down the checklist
might take way too
much time and effort,
while his users
continue to experience
slowness and downtime.
Steve is not really exactly
sure about what to do next.
But then he remembers
a new solution
that might be able to
help, Active Assist.
He recalls that
Active Assist's goal
is to help folks
like him optimize
their Cloud with recommendations
and other tools which
reduce administrative overhead.
This sounds really promising.
So he pulls up the
Recommendation Hub
in the Google Cloud Console.
Steve is pretty excited.
Right away, he is seeing
some recommendations
on how to optimize resources
in his project for performance
and high availability.
He had a feeling that computer
resources on his project
might be overloaded with
all this new demand.
So he navigates to the VM
rightsizing recommendations
first.
He can immediately see that
many VMs on this project
have recently had extremely
high CPU utilization, which
can definitely
result in long queues
and negatively impact
the overall performance
of his application.
And this all is based on
Google Cloud performing
multiple simulations to
select the replacement VMs
optimal for Steve's workload.
So he is confident to apply
these recommendations.
It almost feels too
good to be true.
Things like this used
to take a lot more time
to investigate and fix.
And yet, this can now be
done with only a few clicks.
Now Steve is thinking
about how to best deal
with the spikes in
demand, just like the one
they saw over the
weekend, going forward.
So he turns to the next
intelligent feature
in Active Assist's arsenal.
Steve already relies on Compute
Engine's real-time Autoscaler.
But it appears, though,
that it doesn't work well
for his monolithic
Java application, which
takes more than five
minutes to initialize.
This autoscaling
latency contributes
to the availability issues
that some of his users
have reported.
So he enables
Predictive Autoscaler,
which forecasts future capacity
needs based on historical load
data, and starts up VM instances
ahead of upcoming demand.
Awesome.
Steve just took another
manual task off his plate.
Next, he looks into the
other Auto-healing feature.
As his team's frequent
on-call person,
Steve is definitely
not looking to get
paged in the middle of the night
because of an application crash
caused by a recent bad update,
memory overflow, or something
else.
To prevent this
from happening, he
creates a simple health
check and enables
Compute Engine's Auto-healing.
This feature will
automatically recreate
unhealthy VMs to reduce
the risk of any downtime.
And the best thing, it works
for his stateful workload,
preserving his
applications data.
Now, that he has addressed his
applications' compute capacity
issues that have
been contributing
to the poor performance,
Steve decides
to go deal with that original
issue that Alice has reported,
where some of their
users in Europe
were impacted more than
the rest of the world.
He suspects these problems
might be caused by the network.
And he isn't the
networking expert.
And Steve would typically
hand something like this
off to the networking
team for investigation.
But as he's fighting
the clock, he
decides to open the
network intelligence center
and see what he can
find out on his own.
So he looks at the
performance dashboard
and quickly confirms that
everything within GCP
looks good.
So he opens up the
network topology view
to investigate if
there are any problems
with the external access
that might be contributing
to the high latency.
From this view,
he can immediately
see that something is wrong.
Their users in Europe
are, for some reason,
being served from the
nonoptimal US Central 1 region.
He gives a quick call to his
friend on the networking team.
And they quickly
realize this must
have been caused by
the oversubscribed pool
of compute resources, which
resulted in the global log
balancer automatically
rerouting traffic to the US.
They remedied this issue
quickly by adding more resources
in the Europe region and
reconfiguring the load
balancer.
And while on this topic of
the networking optimization
opportunities, Steve also
notices this VPN tunnel
over utilization recommendation.
This wasn't even top of mind.
But fixing this now could
prevent major headaches later.
Looks like one of the VPN
tunnels on his project
has been approaching
its utilization capacity
and is likely to turn
into a bottleneck
within the next few days.
So he proactively notifies
the networking team
to make sure they look
into adding some redundancy
before this over-utilized
VPN becomes a real problem.
Now, Steve also had a hunch
that his data infrastructure
might not have been
optimally set up either.
Active Assist helps him
to identify one more
immediate opportunity
to optimize
his system for resiliency.
It turns out that
one of his teams
has been using Bigtable
without backing up data.
If one of Steve's
developer colleagues
makes a mistake in
their business logic
and writes some gibberish
into a critical table,
it can be very difficult
to recover from that state.
Following this recommendation,
with just one click,
Steve creates a Dataflow
job to continuously backup
Bigtable data into
Cloud Storage to make
sure it can be restored in
the event of a system failure,
or let's face it, user error.
This seems like another
major improvement
that will let him sleep
through the night, page free.
So Steve calls
Alice and tells her
about a number of
important changes
to the applications'
back end he implemented
to remediate all the
performance issues reported
by their customers.
They both are relieved
that all these changes were
made in just a couple of hours
and with basically no labors,
investigation, custom
scripts, or any significant
administrative overhead.
Excited, Steve goes
back to his desk
and continues poking
around other optimization
opportunities.
He discovers that, in addition
to applying Active Assist
recommendations from within
the Google Cloud Console,
he could also query the
recommender API directly
and incorporate them as a part
of his organization's existing
workflow.
So he decides to
go the extra mile.
And he writes a
code custom script
that pulls new recommendations
from the recommender API
and delivers a digest to
his inbox on a weekly basis.
Steve also shares this
script with his colleagues,
who run other projects, to
help them proactively address
some of these performance
issues as well.
But wait, as soon as he is
done helping Alice manage
this initial performance
application performance crisis,
he has got Bob, their finance
director, knocking at his door.
Bob needs for everyone
across the company
to cut their costs
by at least 25%.
Steve never really liked Bob.
But they sat down together
to think through a few cost
optimization opportunities.
First, there's the total cost
of ownership perspective.
Is it time to start
re-architecting
their self-managed stack and
go completely serverless?
Or maybe they should go use
a different database service.
Or there could be ways
for them to optimize
their current resources.
But how can they do this without
sacrificing their application's
performance and availability?
And finally, there's
the pure finance angle.
With all the cloud products
Steve's team is relying on,
there is a lot of complexity
on the billing side
alone, with literally
hundreds of billable features,
a number of pricing models
and discounts to pick from.
Just like troubleshooting
performance issues,
cost-cutting can be really
hard and can take up
a lot of time and effort.
Short of gathering a team of
architects, DevOps, and finance
folks, Steve decides
to go take a look
at what Active Assist has
to offer in this space.
So he pulls up
Recommendation Hub
and focuses on cost
optimization cards this time.
Right away, he is seeing
some recommendations
for his applications,
computer resources, storage,
and billing.
And he is already familiar with
the rightsizing recommendations
for performance.
So he starts with the ones
that look very similar
but appear to be geared
towards cost savings.
Steve realizes there is a
number of VMs on his project
that are way too
large for the task
that they have been
initially allocated for.
He applies these
recommendations,
realizing substantial
savings from removing
this extra compute capacity
his project didn't really need.
After addressing the
over-provisioning,
he turns to the
unused resources.
This turns out to be
another major contributor
to the high Cloud
spend on his project.
These recommendations
indicate that he
has got a lot of idle
VMs on his project,
possibly from previous
testing or development cycles.
He didn't expect
to see this many.
But he's not really
surprised, as he
knows how easy it is for
people to spin up a VM
and forget about it.
And while on this
topic, he also comes
across another type of vital
resource recommendation.
Turns out, there are quite a few
persistent disks on his project
that haven't been
utilized either.
He realizes substantial
savings by deleting
most of those idle PDs
and archiving the rest
into cold storage.
And Steve is glad
that they won't
be paying for all these
unused resources going forward
and proceeds to look at the
billing model optimization
opportunities to
further reduce costs.
He looked into this Committed
Use Discount concept
a few months ago.
But it seemed just way too
hard to operationalize.
Before Active Assist, he had to
do a lot of things on his own,
starting from understanding
their team's current usage
patterns to figuring
out trade-offs,
versus their current billing
model, which leverages
sustained use
discounts, and finally,
to projecting the impact of
any potential billing model
changes.
So he is very glad to see that
Active Assist has already done
all this heavy lifting for him.
He grabs the screenshot
with projected savings
and sends an email to
Bob, the finance director,
to get his approval to switch
from the on-demand pricing
to a three-year
commitment, which
could slash their compute
cost by almost 50%.
As he moves to the
other billing model
optimization
opportunities, he sees
that Active Assist has
more recommendations
for his project.
They have been using
BigQuery as a data warehouse.
As their application
data has been growing,
more and more people
have been using BigQuery
With their current
on-demand billing model,
their cost has been
steadily going up as well.
This recommendation
is for Steve's project
to consider switching to the
BigQuery slot billing model,
where they can run
as many queries
as they need on a fixed
amount of [INAUDIBLE] slots.
Based on his team's
usage history,
Active Assist estimated they
will save a lot on their bill
without negatively
impacting performance, which
is really important to Steve.
So he takes this up with Bob,
along with his earlier proposal
to switch to the Committed Use
Discounts for compute engine.
They walk through the
resource optimizations
that Steve has
already implemented,
which resulted in
immediate savings,
and also agree on
implementing the billing
model changes that are
expected to yield even more
substantial savings over time.
And as they wrap
up, Bob asks Steve
if he can help apply similar
techniques to other projects
in their organization.
Steve goes back to his
desk to read the manual
and quickly discovers there is
BigQuery Export feature, which
allows him to dump all these
insights and recommendations
to a BigQuery
table and do custom
analysis across their
entire organization.
Steve is already
familiar with BigQuery
since they have been
using it for a lot
of their operational
data anyway.
So a few hours later, he sends
Bob, the finance director,
a link to the dashboard in
Google Cloud's Data Studio
that uncovers
substantial cost savings
opportunities across multiple
projects in their organization.
Having optimized their
cloud infrastructure
for cost and performance,
Steve turns to security.
His organization never
took security lightly.
And Steve feels they have a
good set of in-depth security
measures in place.
Provided their recent
growth, though, as well as
their company's new
work-from-home configuration,
he meets up with Molly, who
is in charge of their security
team.
Together, they sit down
to reassess their security
measures and make sure
they are doing everything
they can to protect the
sensitive information
that their customers
are trusting them with.
A couple of things come to
mind as they go down the list.
Do people have the permissions
they need to do their jobs,
but not more?
Over-granted
permissions can lead
to incidents,
malicious in nature,
as well as the ones caused by
simple, unintentional human
errors, which can also result
in data loss or infrastructure
changes that can be
really hard to revert.
Then there's the
networking layer.
Molly tells Steve she's
worried about this one,
especially after reading a
breach about a competitor who
had an open port,
which permitted traffic
from an insecure
zone, which then
went through a
misconfigured firewall.
Are there any holes in their
firewall configuration?
And there's a whole set
of other considerations
around protecting sensitive data
as well as their very own power
users, who present
a high security
risk if their identities
are compromised.
Steve knows these issues
can be really hard.
But he feels optimistic,
since he already
knows that Active Assist
should be able to help.
This time around, he looks at
the security-related features.
And he is excited to see some
identity and access, as well
as firewall-related
recommendations.
He decides to dig into
the permissions first.
Steve, like many project
owners out there,
wants to enforce the
principle of list privilege,
when all the project
members have access only
to what they really need.
He knows, though, that solving
this at scale is really hard.
Many things can go wrong, from
breaking something running
in production to
slowing his teams down
with way too much process.
It is much easier
said than done.
That's why he's
extremely excited
to see Active Assist's
identity and access
management rightsizing
recommendations that
go beyond just removing
unused permissions,
by using machine learning
algorithms to figure out what
permissions users really need.
So he quickly cleans up all
the inactive service accounts
and also grants smaller and
granular roles to his project
members, literally making
hundreds of accounts
more secure with
only a few clicks.
And as he goes
through this process,
he realizes that he
would love to dig
into a couple of
additional questions
in the context of
some of these changes.
For example, how can I see
who can act as the service
account on my project?
Luckily, Active Assist has him
covered in this one as well.
With Policy Analyzer, Steve is
able to answer this question
and many more.
In addition to the
one he had in mind,
he runs a couple
of other queries.
Which VMs can John delete?
Who has right access on
this BigQuery data set?
It feels like magic.
But wait a minute.
Steve sees a service account
that is able to access
the BigQuery data set that
it probably shouldn't.
He wants to remove the
service account access,
but wants to make sure that
he doesn't break anything
in the process.
With Policy Simulator, he
can check the proposed policy
changes against the
90-day access history
to see if these changes would
block any essential access
which was previously used.
And just as Steve wraps
up with Policy Simulator,
he has someone come to
him with this dreaded,
"I'm getting a denied
error" problem.
These seemingly simple
issues can be surprisingly
hard to troubleshoot.
They can be caused by
a number of factors.
It could be a lack of a
certain permission, or group
membership, or a
combination of IM
and network policies
causing this denial.
So Steve is relieved to
be able to use the Policy
Troubleshooter to confirm that
this particular user never
had any access granted to
them in the first place.
So he adds them
to a group, which
provides just the
right amount of access
they need to do their job.
Steve feels that he
is now in the position
to not only establish the
principle of list privilege,
but actually
maintain it, instead
of simply granting all
permissions to everyone
who comes to him with
"my access isn't working"
type of an issue.
Next, he turns to the network.
Firewall is one of the most
fundamental protection layers.
Managing, however, is a
major challenge for Steve.
His firewall configuration
grew really complex
as more and more access
was added over time.
So he is afraid
to even touch it,
as he knows that this will
likely break something.
That's why Steve is relieved
to see these firewall
insights from Active Assist.
He starts with the
unused firewall rules,
which can potentially
allow an unwanted access
and present a major security
risk to his organization.
Steve then looks at the
firewall optimization insights.
Active Assist also brings
to his attention things
like unreachable and
misconfigured roles,
which could be redundant.
He's happy to see
these insights as well,
as they help him simplify
his firewall configuration
and make it much
easier to manage
and maintain going forward.
But as he cleans up his
firewall configuration,
this thought crosses
Steve's mind again.
What if I break
something in production
by doing these changes?
Luckily, Active Assist has him
covered in this one as well.
Using the Connectivity
Test feature
from the Network
Intelligence Center,
Steve can double check the
impact of configuration changes
as he applies them.
And this gives him confidence
in a couple of especially tricky
scenarios, where if
he wasn't 100% sure
if it was OK to remove a
particular firewall rule.
Having his firewall
configuration optimized,
Steve turns to one
more security gap.
He heard at a recent
conference that roughly 30%
of annual enterprise data
breaches involve phishing.
He knows he should
look into this.
But it's tough to
roll out and enforce
a policy around authentication
with multiple teams, systems,
and vendors that his
company is relying on.
The good news is he can now
turn to Active Assist for help.
He enables a phone as a
security key recommendation
for his organization's
most at-risk users,
like the ones who
have broad permissions
and a substantial blast
radius if their accounts
are compromised.
And the best thing,
it's free and only
takes two minutes to set up.
Happy about the
substantial progress
he was able to make so quickly,
Steve sits down with Molly
to go over these
important security
gaps he was able to close.
And it's a win-win for everyone.
The project team can still
maintain the flexibility
and velocity, thanks to the
efficient troubleshooting
and analysis tooling that Active
Assist provides in addition
to the security insights and
recommendations themselves.
And the security team is happy
with the substantially reduced
attack surface,
which is getting them
much closer to the zero-trust
environment that they want.
Molly asks Steve if he can
help make this work at scale
with other projects
in their organization,
and especially with
their new GitOps approach
to administering the most
sensitive parts of their cloud
infrastructure,
such as permissions.
They want to use
GitHub to do everything
declaratively and centrally.
And Steve already
has the answer.
While looking into the
recommender API and BigQuery
Export earlier, he came
across this reference solution
in the documentation, which can
help them do exactly what Molly
is asking for.
He downloads this reference
implementation from GitHub,
polishes it.
And a couple of hours later,
folks on their security team
start seeing some
recommendations presented
as pull requests against their
configuration stored in Git.
To recap, we looked
at several examples
of how Active Assist
can help improve
your workloads, performance,
availability, and scalability,
optimize your cloud
infrastructure cost,
and improve your
security posture.
To get started
with Active Assist,
we encourage you to visit our
website and Recommendation Hub
in Cloud Console to see if
there are some recommendations
already waiting for you.
Now, some of the features
that we highlighted today
are only available
in limited preview.
If you are interested in
getting early access to all
the new features as
they get developed,
we encourage you to join our
Active Assist Trusted Tester
group, which is linked
from our website.
And finally, check out these
cloud Cloud OnAir sessions
for deeper dives into
some of the features
that we talked about.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.